[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat politique
on a dit qu'il allait servir de fusible
après cette crise
or la cote de popularité du premier
ministre devance largement celle du
président après deux mois de confinement
y at il des tensions entre le couple
exécutif alors que le parti présidentiel
subic la fronde d'une partie des
marcheurs de la première heure le
maquereau nisme à l'épreuve du virus et
la question ce soir nous sommes nous
avec patrick mennucci ancien député ps
et conseiller municipal de marseille
bonsoir patrick mennucci face à vous
florian philippot conseiller régional du
grand est et président de patriotes dont
soir florian philippot bonsoir merci
beaucoup à tous les deux d'être sur rt
france premier conseil des ministres
post confinement s'était mercredi le
président de la république était présent
avec son premier ministre edouard
philippe
depuis le début de la crise les annonces
du premier ministre ont souvent été
contredite par l'elysée mais tout va
bien assure emmanuel macron corriger le
tir en permanence ça faisait partie de
la stratégie écoutez le je souhaitais
qu'on puisse voir ce qui se déroule bien
parce que je pense que c'est la
philosophie qu'on avait adopté depuis le
début avec le premier ministre de le
corriger constamment d'ajuster le tir si
besoin était patrick mennucci alors
c'est vrai qu'on a eu beaucoup de
d'ordre contre ordre évidemment il ya le
caractère imprévisible du corona
violence mais quand même mais il faut
accorder ses violons quand on tient
l'exécutif noms ou des gros que c'est
un peu inhérents à ce qu'on appelle le
maquereau nisme depuis le début et la
crise du coc vide à amplifier évidemment
de cette ce sentiment mais cette réalité
que nous partageons tout ce qu' un
gouvernement qui prend des décisions
comment dire de façon un peu aléatoire
et je pense que c'est dans la nature de
d'ulm acronis mais c'est d'ailleurs même
revendiquer puisque on a cette fameuse
ce fameux en même temps qui est utilisé
chaque fois qu'on veut expliquer quelque
chose et diront le contraire
immédiatement
donc c'est pas surprenant qu au moment
où la crise est la plus forte et où il
faut des dirigeants qui avaient des
conceptions des principes une
administration qui soit qui ne dirigent
pas mais comme dirige
et bien c'est à ces moments là que les
choses se révèle peut-être plus
violemment encore que dans le coin de
l'activité gouvernementale et voilà
c'est ça que vous pointez foresti qu'est
ce que vous en pensez florian philippot
qu'est ce que ça dit cette façon de
dénoncer des choses par par par l'elysée
puis elles sont contredites par le
premier ministre ou vice versa cette
façon de gouverner ça dit quoi du
gouvernement actuel selon vous je pense
qu'il y a chez emmanuel macron un vrai
sentiment de perdition
d'ailleurs il a l'air authentiquement
quand ils s'expriment perdu et même
parfois perche et enfin quand il s'est
exprimé sur la culture complètement
ébouriffés avec des expressions
totalement l étonnante chevaucher le
tigre me semble t'il
personne ne comprenait ce qui se passait
hilale a perdu depuis le début de cette
crise alors qu'edouard philips est vrai
qu en contraste au vent il al'air
peut-être plus sérieux peut-être plus
rare de croiser inquiétant et si macron
me semble à ce point perdu c'est que
toutes ces certitudes toutes les
certitudes du maquereau nisme pour
reprendre votre terme s'effondre et je
crois qu'ils sont il en a bien
conscience toutes les bêtises sur la
start up nation les premiers de cordée
alors on a bien vu qu'en fait c'étaient
les premiers core v qui est y faisait
tenir bon la france pendant cette crise
toutes ces bêtises là tout son logiciel
idéologique complètement balayé par la
crise et je crois qu'il est
authentiquement perdu qui n'arrive pas à
le gérer parfois les nerfs prennent le
dessus
donc il est dans un état de sidération
parfois étonnants parfois inquiétant et
il a perdu pied me semble-t-il dans
cette crise
contrairement à son premier ministre
alors résultat le prémice gac des points
dans les sondages et l'écart se creuse
ce qui n'est jamais bon signe pour le
premier ministre parce que généralement
quand dans un exécutif le produit
devient beaucoup plus populaire que le
président atypique ça sent la fin
tu trouves ministre alors c'est ce
qu'ils disent est en tout cas qu'il y
avait un petit peu de l'eau dans le gaz
entre edouard philippe et emmanuel
lacroix est ce que vous confirmez
patrick mennucci je crois que là il n'y
a pas eu il suffit de regarder
excusez moi j'étais un peu surpris par
votre demande de confirmation
emmanuel macron des mots oui oui mais ça
c'est aussi le sait depuis georges
pompidou et le général de gaulle mais
c'était pas le même type d'individu on
dit qu'il y a un problème avec le
président de la république pour ministre
michel rocard françois mitterrand
d'autres sarkozy tout ça et est assez
classique de la vème république
le problème c'est que ce classicisme de
la vème république se heurte à une
situation terrifiante pour les français
qui à un moment ce jeu politicien est
extrêmement désagréable et c'est vrai
que le premier ministre a donné plus le
sentiment aux français de solidité que
le président république mais je crois
que c'est normal
le premier ministre a une expérience
politique
moi je les connais à l'assemblée
nationale c'est clair il a été maire il
il connaît les citoyens il connaît les
élus locaux il connaît les territoires
le président république il est
certaine façon hors sol dans cette
situation mais vous nous aviez posé la
question comme thème delà du débat ce
sort est ce que le maquereau nisme et le
virus est à l'épreuve du virus moi je
dirais que avant le virus c'est-à-dire
quelques jours avant aux élections
municipales le maquereau nice n'a été à
l'épreuve des français et ça a été une
véritable catastrophe pour la république
en marche il faut se rappeler que toutes
les opérations qui ont été montés au
niveau municipal ont été des désastres à
à poitiers à strasbourg a parlé on a peu
parlé puisque la crise
mais puisque vous poser cette question
est aussi intéressante puisque il va y
avoir un deuxième tour et il ya ceux qui
étaient purement lrm qui ont été balayés
et puis il ya ceux qui dans la droite
française avait voulu avoir le soutien
des les roms qui aussi ont été balayés
regarder la situation de monsieur
moudenc à toulouse ou de monsieur
hainard
à nancy ils ont été tirés vers le bas
par leur soutien
le soutien du maquereau nisme donc on
voit bien qu'avant les péripéties de du
gouvernement sous le coup vides il y
avait la réalité comme parfaitement
somme si les français le 15 mars dernier
on va écouter doit filer puisque le 7
mai dernier un journaliste lui a posé la
question pour savoir si tout allait bien
entre lui et emmanuel macron et écoutez
sa réponse
j'ai toujours eu dans nos relations
constater il me réjouir d'une confiance
d'une fluidité qui je crois a peu de
précédents
et voilà c'est toujours le cas et
j'espère que ce sera toujours le cas et
je crois que ce sera toujours le cas et
je pense que nos concitoyens s'en
contrefichent dans des proportions qu à
mon avis les journalistes politiques ne
mesure pas et je dois dire que de ce
point de vue là je me sens très français
je vous remercie pas savoir est ce que
les journalistes politiques selon vous
je trouve que le langage corporel du
premier ministre trahissait le fond de
sa pensée
ça ne concordaient pas entre ce qu'il
disait il avait l'air très mal à l'aise
sur sur ce sujet en réalité
contrairement à ce qu'il dit ça
n'intéresse plus les gens et politique
bien sûr parce que ça paraît politiciens
face à l'est pas tant que ça parce que
parce que la coordination entre le chef
de l'état et celui qui dirige de fait le
gouvernement est normalement qui prend
les décisions pour le pour l'essentiel
des affaires de la nation c'est le
premier ministre c'est quand même
fondamental aussi pour savoir à quelle
sauce on va être mangé surtout quand on
est en pleine crise donc c'est quand
même important
mais au-delà de ça moi je pense si vous
voulez que je reviens à cette idée s'il
ya une raison pour lier le caractère
dont acron et parfois fantasque étonnant
si d'errance mais il ya une raison de
fond c'est que toutes les il ya un virus
dans la machine macro liste bien virus
et bien un argus dans la start up nation
quand on nous dit qu'il faut relocaliser
en france la production parce que ça
paraît aujourd'hui consensuel ce matin
lui misé l'économie disait que les
délocalisations ç'avait été une énorme
faute enfin merci de dire qu'il entend
après pital aujourd'hui avec emmanuel
macron d'ailleurs bien sûr idem pour les
moyens de l'hôpital et tant d'autres
sujets c'est le problème c'est que
macron a toujours fait l'inversé enfin
qui a laissé partir les entreprises qui
a encore là il ya quelques semaines
laisser l'union européenne signé des
accords de libre échange avec le mexique
et le vietnam en plein pendant la crise
d'ailleurs pas falloir que macro nous
explique tout ça qui a laissé les
fleurons nationaux alstom et tant
d'autres partir c'est macron c'est le
maquereau nice vidéo logique même qui
dépasse macro et donc c'est pour ça on
avis qu'il a un énorme fêlures interne
entre ce qu'il dit et ce qu'il pense ou
ce qu'il a pensé profondément est-ce
qu'il a professé ce qu'il a fait et ça
rend forcément mal à l'aise ça sera
lui par des bouchers parfois délirantes
chevaucher le tigre pour moi c'est une
bouffée délirante et avoir un président
de république est une bouffée délirante
on a connu ça du temps des channels a
mal fini c'est pas rassurant ça n'est
pas rassurant patrick mennucci on a même
entendu le chef de la france info me
jean luc mélenchon dire que le premier
ministre avait de l'élégance
contrairement au président marine le pen
également dit que l'un est inverse de
l'autre qu'est-ce que alors vous parlez
de l'utérus et du maquereau nice mais ce
que c'est la fin de cette de cette
politique d' emmanuel macron qui qui qui
a cours en tout cas en france maintenant
depuis de plus de 2 en moyenne
je crois que marine le pen et jean luc
melenchon mme houde taureau mais bonne
c'est dans leur nature de 2,2 de sombrer
parce que soutenir le premier ministre
ou dix ans que le premier ministre est
formidable pour le comparer au président
la république c'était un peu grotesque
parce que le premier ministre même s'il
paraît plus solide on est tous d'accord
là dessus il a conduit la politique du
maquereau nice depuis deux ans d'une
façon tout à fait déterminé et décisive
dans la question de l'élégance de
l'homme pourquoi pas mais en fait ça ne
règle rien moi ce qu'il me semble terre
c'est justement que il n'y a pas fait il
ya quand même quelque chose qui est
incroyable c'est que en moi parfois
peut-être même quinze jours on a
abandonné tous les oripeaux en tout cas
pas du libéralisme le libéralisme a été
liquidée dans
dans les jours les plus sombres de la de
l'épidémie dans les moments où il y
avait beaucoup de gens animation où il y
avait 500 par jour c'est lé moment où le
libéralisme a été liquidée et puis vous
voyez qu avec la l'espoir qui renaît de
sortir de ce sud de cette épidémie
alors on retrouve les vieux réflexes
on reparle de thé à travailler plus les
salariés plutôt que d'augmenter les
personnels des hôpitaux on demande aux
salariés de donner des jours de congés
en fait on est sur des logiques de
charité alors que les français attendent
des logiques de dd logique normale
c'est-à-dire de la rémunération réelle
du travail qu'ont fourni dont les uns et
les autres se sont aperçu de
l'importance de ces personnels qui dans
les ehpad je le rappelle gagne environ
1200 euros par mois et qui s'occupe des
personnes âgées le voilage je crois que
c'est ça qui est terrible et que les
français ne peuvent pas combat parce que
ce n'est pas le virus qui va justifier
le changement de pied politique ce qui
justifie le changement de pied politique
c'est le fait qu'on n'a pas
d'orientation ou que l'orientation ghosn
a aussi dit tiens elle va pas me
permettre d'être réélu donc je vais en
prendre à l arrière il ya aussi des
mécontents patrick mennucci dont la
majorité puisque deux députés de la
république en marche vont probablement
former un neuvième groupe à l'assemblée
nationale dès lundi prochain ce qui a
mis le feu aux poudres c'est est ce ce
fameux vatan à l'issue du plan
déconfinement annoncé par edouard
philippe
écoutez ce qu'on disait guillaume chiche
député la république en marge des
d'auxerre il fait partie des frondeurs
quoi de plus normal qu'un délai d'une
journée pour voter l'ensemble de la
stratégie de déconfinement en plus
accepté cette requête aurait favorisé la
concorde nationale il est légitime que
le gouvernement veuille présenter son
plan le
vite possible mais il met tous les
parlementaires y compris ceux de sa
majorité dans une situation très
délicate
florian philippot c'est pas nouveau
cette façon assez arbitraire finalement
de dire au député quoi voter et quand
c'est fini cette cette méthode vous
pensez que ce groupe va vraiment aller
en tout cas aller comme bon lui semble
selon ses convictions il va suivre
toujours la république en marche je suis
incapable de vous le dira peut-être
qu'il y a quand même parmi la majorité
très large à l'époque de député en
marche qui avait été lui des gens qui
ont une conscience qui voit bien que ça
ce qu'ils font ne correspond pas à ce
qu'ils pensent et qui en tire les
conclusions on peut toujours leur
donnait d'abord les excuses de bonne foi
on verra bien j'ai envie dit on va le
savoir très vite de toute façon si c'est
purement tacticien ou si c'est sincère
ce qui est certain c'est que c'est quand
même un désastre pour le président
république et le gouvernement parce
qu'il avait une majorité très large en
2017 il s'est peu à peu étiolé et là il
perd sa majorité absolue en réalité ça
va donner d'ailleurs un peu de pouvoir à
gbagbo et à attendre la semaine
prochaine avant de dire oui il est très
probable j'avais raison si on est on va
rester prudent mais si ça se fait
effectivement c'est ce qu'il va perdre
sa majorité absolue ce qui redonnera
unis s'y attendait pas un peu de pouvoir
à françois bayrou parce que la majorité
absolue dépendra du bon vouloir du modem
l'allié de dents marche mais serveuse
nous dira aussi si vous est ce que ça
nous dit c'est que la fable de la
société civile s'avère nous a survendu
ça en 2017
sa lettre la révolution parce qu'on
avait des députés 350 je ne sais plus
combien et qui venait de la société
civile et ça changeait tournage avait
très bien compris ce que ça voulait dire
parce que on est à peu près tous dans la
société civile en fait à part
quelques-uns complètement déconnecté ma
faim globalement c'est quand même assez
rare et on nous a dit ça va toujours les
ballons ça n'a rien changé
les logiques politiciennes on était là
on n'a pas vu des députés flamboyant
bien au contraire et ça n'a pas amélioré
la vie les français c'est surtout ça
l'essentiel pour moi de la leçon de
votre réaction patrick mennucci et à la
formation d'un neuvième groupe à
l'assemblée
j'écoutais les propos de
de monsieur chiche que vous avez
reproduit et je me disais connaît
uniquement sur des questions de forme
ce qui est important c'est pas de savoir
s'il faut laisser un jour de plus à
l'assemblée pour se prononcer c'est
évident qu'il veut fallait et c'est bien
que ce député le 10 mai ce qui est
important c'est le contenu
c'est pas c'est pas la forme on voit
bien que c'est ces députés
moi je suis moins optimiste peut forer
un filippo parce que je ne crois pas du
tout que ce groupe là soit issu d'une
volonté qui souhaitent exprimer de
rompre avec le maquereau nisme je crois
que c'est un moyen d'aborder vu qu'il
veut simple écologistes c'est pas très
bien pourquoi puisque avec tous les
votes confessé députés depuis trois ans
je vois pas comment ils peuvent se
réclamer locaux gym est très bien et
donc c'est manifestement la démocratie
voilà
mais c'est sûrement une petite opération
aussi pour essayer de capter de
l'écologie ou du sud 2 2 2 ce qui est
dans l'air en france
c'est la question goji que je crois que
ce sont des opérations de peu d'intérêt
et que maintenant ce qui est ce qui va
compter c'est la capacité des partis
politiques traditionnels du parti
socialiste et et des républicains d'être
capable d'opposer un candidat pour aller
vers un deuxième tour
je dirais qu'ils permettent de
s'affronter dans des visions de la
république et de la france qui pourrait
permettre aux français de trancher et
non pas de cette espèce de de
salmigondis qui nous est proposé depuis
trois heures qui ont aidé la femme dans
les mains des partis politiques
florian philippot il reste 30 secondes
et crise révèle les hommes c'est ce
qu'on dit en général ça arrive et
lectrices selon vous ça n'a pas révélé
manuel macron ça c'est moins qu'on
puisse dire ça n'a pas révélé grand
monde sa a révélé les soignants mais on
le savait déjà mais on sait que les gens
qu'on tape etc ont matraqués ou gazés
hier il ya trois mois dans les
manifestations même chose pour les
pompiers d'ailleurs et puis tout ce qui
était dans les mains vides
gilet jaune qui se retrouvent qui se
retrouvaient à faire tourner le pays
moralité c'est eux qui étaient les plus
courageux et les plus solides dans cette
crise juste pour rebondir sur ce que le
débat en marche contre l air ou ps moi
j'y crois pas du tout c'est la même
c'est le même moule idéologique
d'ailleurs en marche avec une fusion
entre l air et ps n'y aurait pas de
débat tranché entre deux versions de
l'européisme et du mondialisme c'est pas
ça un débat tranché alors on en
reparlera on n'a plus le temps
malheureusement c'est la fin de ce débat
merci patrick mennucci on a vu vous
n'étiez pas d'accord et merci florian
philippot des yeux vous participez à ce
face à face politique mais merci à vous
pour leur fidélité rester avec nous sur
rt france